the Jets might be the most unlucky team
in sports history they had the defense
the offensive weapons and they thought
they finally had their QB but all that
hype only lasted four plays in Aaron
Rodgers's debut when he went down and it
only got worse Rogers ended up tearing
his Achilles and now he is out for the
entire season think about what the Jets
were getting with Rogers he's a
four-time MVP that's one of the best
quarterbacks this league has ever seen
and the Jets who felt like they were
just one quarterback away were getting
more than what they bargained for now
you're probably thinking they could just
run this thing back with Roger's fix he
said well there's one major problem
Aaron is 39 and currently the oldest
player in the league he also
contemplated retiring before signing
with the Jets so coming back from this
injury may be way tougher than expected
but all Jets fans had their eyes set on
one thing this year the Super Bowl and
with Rogers now gone their chances might
be gone too